Let's go next to our caller from the five
one nine area code.
Who's calling today from five one nine?
And just as importantly, where are you calling
from?
David?
Yes.
OK.
It's really from Owen Sound, Ontario, Canada.
Got a question for you.
Yes.
Do you think that maybe Mr. Trump is just
fed up with the job and is deliberately trying
to sabotage his reelection?
I think he wants to go golfing, I think.
Yeah.
You're not ready for him.
You're not the only person to ask about out
of office.
He can raise all the hell he wants.
Yeah.
Not have to take any responsibility for it.
Right.
Your views on that.
Let's hear.
A few people have asked me about this.
Save a night.
David, I can't hear you.
My phone's acting up, so I'm just going to
hang up and watch for your response on the
show sometime.
OK, ok.
That sounds fine.
Listen, I don't believe Trump is consciously
trying to sabotage or sabotage his own election.
I think Trump's ego won't let him do it.
But I do believe that if Trump loses, he will
justify it by saying, hey, you know what?
It was rigged.
And I have plenty of things to do.
I'm still a rich guy.
I'm still going to be able to go and, you
know, do do whatever it is that I want.
So I don't think Trump is deliberately sabotaging
himself.
I think from the beginning, Trump didn't really
want to be president.
And were the Republican electorate not so
easily bamboozled, Bill?
If that's a word, Trump never would have become
their nominee and would never be president
to this day.
But, yeah, I think that if Trump is trying
to sabotage his election, he's doing it subconsciously,
not consciously.
And then he will, after the fact, certainly
say I'm better off doing doing other stuff
anyway.